hello boys and girls this is tim ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
tim ferriss show where it is my job to
attempt to deconstruct world-class
performers of all different types from
all different disciplines
to give you techniques perhaps tactics
favorite books
training regimens even recovery
protocols even that you can use
and my guests today are the best
at what they do michael phelps
and grant hackett they're very close
friends
they were able to feed off of each other
their shared stories are incredible so
the combination of the two on this
podcast was really special
now let me read these bios and then
we'll jump right in
to the conversation michael phelps you
recognize his name on twitter at
michael phelps is widely regarded as one
of the greatest athletes of all time
he captured 28 medals including a
record-setting 23 gold medals and set 39
world records over the course of his
career phelps utilized his performance
bonus for winning
eight gold medals in 2008 to establish
the michael phelps foundation which
promotes water safety
healthy living physical and mental and
the pursuit of dreams the foundation's
signature program
i am is a learn to swim healthy living
and goal-setting curriculum
based on the principles and tools phelps
utilized in his swimming career
and is available through the boys and
girls clubs of america and special
olympics international
his advocacy for water safety and mental
health
has earned the recognition of the boys
and girls clubs of america
champion of youth american image awards
that's the humanitarian award
substance abuse and a mental health
services administration
special recognition award the ruderman
family foundation
morton e ruderman award and inclusion
and pr week health influencer 50 and
2020 communicator of the year
among many others phelps served as an
executive producer and featured talent
in the hbo documentary the weight of
gold which explores the mental health
challenges olympic athletes often face
although it really extends to many many
more
people and types of people than olympic
athletes in addition he has published
two autobiographies
no limits subtitled the world to succeed
and beneath the surface
that were new york times and usa today
bestsellers and one children's book
how to train with a t-rex and win eight
gold medals you can find him online
on twitter twitter.com forward slash
michael phelps
facebook facebook.com forward slash
michael phelps and on instagram
underscore phelps00 grant hackett
on instagram at grant underscore
underscore hackett that's two
underscores so i'll give that to you
again at
grant underscore underscore h-a-c-k-e
represented in captain australia in
swimming at the olympic games he
collected a total of 58 medals over the
course of his swimming career with
26 gold at olympic commonwealth and
world championship levels
along with 16 world records he remained
unbeaten for 11 years
in his pet event the 1 500 meter
freestyle
that's just nuts grant also received
prestigious honors such as the order of
australia
the centenary medal and the australian
sports
medal grant is a member of the sports
australia hall of fame
and international swimming hall of fame
his qualifications
include also an executive masters of
business administration
with first class honors a diploma of
business law and a diploma of financial
services grant is the ceo of generation
life
an australia-based investment firm
managing more than
1.3 billion dollars so with all that
said
please enjoy michael phelps and grant
hackett
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30 percent of americans
struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes of
poor sleep and heat has always been my
nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now i am
falling asleep
in record time faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device
called the pod pro cover by eight sleep
it's the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
ate sleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just raving
fans of this
so i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress and
start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110
degrees fahrenheit it also splits your
bed in half so your partner can choose a
totally different temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures on
either side which is exactly what we're
doing
now for me and for many people the
result eight sleep users fall asleep up
to 32 percent faster
reduce sleep interruptions by up to 40
percent and get more restful sleep
overall i can personally attest to this
because i track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling refreshed and now my dear
listeners that's you guys
you can get 250 off of the pod pro cover
that's a lot
simply go to eight sleep dot com slash
tim
or use code tim that's eight all spelled
out
e-i-g-h-t sleep dot com
slash tim or use coupon code tim
t-i-m eight sleep dot com slash tim
for 200 off your pod pro cover
this episode is brought to you by
butcherbox butcherbox makes it easy for
you to get high quality humanely raised
meat that you can trust
they deliver delicious 100 grass-fed
grass-finished beef
free-range organic chicken heritage
breed pork and wild caught seafood
directly to your door for me in the past
few weeks
i've cooked a ton of their salmon as
well as two delicious barbecue rib racks
in the oven
super simple they were the most
delicious pork ribs i've ever prepared
and my freezer is full of butcher box
when you become a member
you're joining a community focused on
doing what's better for all that means
caring about the lives of animals
the livelihoods of farmers treating our
planet with respect and enjoying
better meals together butcherbox
partners with folks small farmers
included who believe in going above and
beyond
when it comes to caring for animals the
environment and sustainability
and none of their meat is ever given
antibiotics or added hormones
so how does it work it's pretty simple
you choose your box and your delivery
frequency they offer five boxes four
curated box options as well as the
popular custom box so you get exactly
what you
and or your family love box options and
delivery frequencies can be customized
to fit your needs you can cancel
at any time with no penalty butcherbox
ships your order frozen for freshness
and packed in an eco-friendly 100
recyclable box it's easy it's fast
it's convenient i really really enjoy it
and best of all
looking at the average cost it works out
to be less than six dollars per meal
get ready for game day or a cozy night
in with butcher box
right now new members will get one rack
of st louis style ribs
one pack of bacon and a pack of pulled
pork for free
in their first box by going to
butcherbox.com
tim one more time that's butcherbox.com
tim at this altitude i can run flat out
for a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
michael and grant welcome to the show
thank you tim thanks for having us
of course thank you what's up grant it's
real thrilled to have us
all together i've this was the da vinci
code of scheduling the formats last
theorem of coordination because we have
people in every possible time zone and
multiple countries so i appreciate you
guys being flexible with
with making it happen and i thought we
would start
with difficult or particularly
notable races and i'd love to start with
you grant because
i was confessing to both of you before
we started i
enjoy swimming i actually didn't even
learn to swim until i was in my 30s
which is a whole separate story but i
really enjoy swimming but i know very
very little about competition
and the history of competitions and
notable races and so on
grant can you please speak to and
describe for people what happened in the
2004 olympics
in the 1500 meter freestyle
yeah that was a particularly tough
olympics for me um
that year i actually got pneumonia at
the start of the year because i was just
over training i
got a little bit sick and i never missed
a session and
you know i used to do sort of 8k on
average per session and uh and used to
flog myself and then i got pneumonia
went to hospital that turned into a
chronic chest infection because i didn't
stop training as soon as i came out of
hospital because i couldn't because i'd
missed the olympic games
and then when i got to to the olympics
in athens in in 2004 i then
i think one objective was to to win
three gold medals and uh
i got two gold medals uh both by point
one of a second
two silver medals sorry by point one of
a second and uh i wasn't too happy about
that
then i raced the 1500 meter freestyle
and i actually had to deal with a
partially collapsed lung on my my left
side
um because it was blocked with mucus for
so long that that
race i probably pushed myself through
more pain than i've ever had and uh
one of michael's teammates uh larson
jensen was breaking the american record
and you know by about 12 seconds doing a
personal best time and
so it pushed me to to the nth degree and
that was brutal i came home i
went under a cat scan and they said oh
there's a massive lump on your lungs
we're gonna have to inject you with
iodine just to see what's going on
and you know they said oh it's a big
ball and and you know eject me with
iodine how to look and
they said oh it's okay it's okay and i
said what do you mean is it okay and
they said well your lower left lobe has
got no oxygen for it for so long that
it's actually just deflated
and it's just sitting up on a big ball
and i've got a huge lung capacity of
12.6 liters and apparently that took
something like a quarter of it
off so that that race to win that gold
medal was
was the most painful moment um that i've
ever had in my career and yeah
but probably the most rewarding at the
same time but certainly after that i
promised i would never
never race like that again and michael
knows how much of a sore spot that 4x2
freestyle relay was a few days before
where we lost by 0.1
so i've two follow-up questions related
to this
the first is you mentioned lung capacity
12.6 liters
do you have any idea just as a point of
reference what
average uh muggle heart capacity is like
normie as one of my olympic friends put
it normies
what that is compared to a non-olympic
swimming champion lung capacity
so when that was done because i'm
referring to actually the stats in 2004
it's 160 above what it should be uh for
my heart yeah
and my age at the time so yeah it was
12.63 liters my total on capacity so
yeah one of those genetic things that
helps
you know it's at that level it's with
swimming and a lot of sports it's like
at the
you know junior high level you see all
sorts of different body types and then
as you get a little bit higher
you see still different body types but
they there's a point where they start to
converge
uh on on very particular sets of
physical characteristics on the lung so
partially collapsed lung that to most
people listening that just seems
completely
baffling because so much of swimming
would seem dependent
on utilizing your full lung capacity
what did it feel like is it painful but
what does it
feel like to swim
at max capacity with a partially
collapsed lung
it's not good tim let me tell you that
uh the way i describe that race is like
putting
handcuffing someone to a treadmill
putting on a max incline max speed
and then just going for for 15 minutes
um that that was the intensity of the
pain normally where i felt that intense
pain at the thousand meter mark i felt
at the 500 meter mark in that race
and it's excruciating those thresholds
that you have to go through so
yeah to push myself through that the
funniest thing about that race i
i hadn't lost it in eight years at that
particular point in time and
i am was going to last hundred meters
and it was the first time it actually
turned with someone next to me with a
hundred meters to go
and uh and i actually came home faster
in the last hundred meters than what i
did than when i broke the world record
by by seven seconds three years earlier
so um
it actually taught me the value of
competition in my worst situation that i
can actually
extrapolate or get more um out of myself
even even feeling like that but the pain
was yeah i actually said i'm going to
retire if i can't get better
after those olympics i'm actually going
to retire from the sport because i
didn't want to race like that again
why are you doing like day testing than
hackie yeah
yeah we were doing do you remember what
it would have been after that
you know it's funny it was never that
high after my 15 but i think i hit about
a 12
after that where the the 200 i could hit
a 13 or 14
and the 15 would normally be like a 9
but i produced
more there because the oxygen saturation
wasn't going down
into my blood so yeah so it went up
that's a good point no one's actually
ever mentioned that mp
well that's a great question that's just
something i like snap think about
because i mean
like i mean you know me like i was
always somebody who and still am like a
just a numbers driven person so that
stuff always just
sends little key messages whether it's
to me or or to bob or to keene and my
trainer of things we need to improve on
or fix or
maybe what we need to get tested for too
so yeah
absolutely no that was excruciating but
you still want to see
stats afterwards it's like the olympics
is over that's the last day always of
the olympics
and you know you would have been doing
the 4x1 medley probably that day as well
and you know you still want to do
everything like you know see what you
how quickly you remove the lactate out
of your muscles after you cool down
and that's one thing that michael and i
always share is the stats like we can
pull out any
swimming time any split any world record
split we we know it back to front
i was going to continue with the the
tough race
question and michael you can feel free
to go there first but
i also have a question about
that training obsession competitive
drive and also just the
familiarity with the numbers right i do
have some questions about that but
do you have a particularly tough race or
competition that that you'd like to
mention
michael in the 200 fly i'm really happy
it was only 200 meters
uh in in 2016
had it been 201 meters i would have lost
so
that one sticks out other than that like
i i look
back at you know most of my races and
and i can say
they were pretty much pain free but that
was just because i was prepared
that literally is the only reason um
so you know i was probably 75 80
of the time really prepared um and
and you know 2012 and
like 10 to 12 are kind of my fake
65 70 ish let's talk about prep since
that's that's where
i was gonna head next i'm looking at a
quote uh
from your coach michael from 2003 and
he's
he's referring to both of you guys and
he's asked about the similarities
between the two of you and he said this
is from
an interview at some point they both
enjoy training it's not an ordeal for
them they're both really aware of what's
going on in practice in relation to
their times
speed where everyone is and most
importantly where they are in training
compared to their goals
and i'm sure you guys get questions
about competitive drive all the time so
i don't want to obsess
on that phrasing exactly but
is that familiarity with the numbers and
that awareness
common across other
team members or or is that something
that is abnormally developed
in the two of you and if so do you have
any theories on on why that is
yeah i i i think like a lot of it really
is just
god-given feel and ability right like
you know for me like i'm i'm somebody
who is is
really a field swimmer and i was taught
you know the process of it
so um i i was taught to swim as
efficiently as i possibly
could at all times so you know i think
that's really what
allowed me to to be able to do the
you know the repeats and feel the exact
times with the stroke counts or
you know whatever we were trying to do
but also just um
i mean for me it was like like training
training i knew i had to be perfect if i
ever wanted to
do something that no one had ever done
right like i was trying to compete and
do things that people had never seen
before period in the olympics and and
swimming so it's like
i had to you know from a workout
standpoint i had to be as hungry as
possible and
and you know bob kind of says jump and
i'm i'm
always saying how high and and you know
i always wanted to break as many world
records as i possibly could so
that's why i love training and and you
know i know that
you can ask hackie and i think he'd
agree that you put the two of us in a
pool together training
it is is i mean it's pretty much like
we're
we're we're going toe to toe no matter
what it is no matter what stroke it is
just basically trying to rip each
other's head off and and just the pure
love and competition of what we do
i think that that's something that made
us very special but i mean like the feel
like i think that's
you know that's something that that only
one two
three four percent of people five
percent of people in the top of
of all sports probably really have any
idea what we're talking about
it's quite it's quite funny i think um
just when michael was talking then i
started thinking of the movie days of
thunder when they're in the wheelchair
in the hospital
and they come up they push forward and
then the other one pushes forward
that's exactly how michael and i train
together it's just
just constantly pushing each other and
and trying to take it to the next level
and um you just disregard the pain in
that the goal is always more important
the outcome is always more important
than what you have to go through i think
that's the way we always approached it
i'd love to
as background for people listening
provide some context on how
the two of you know each other and those
in the swimming world will know
the the history and the similarities
from in trajectory and so on
but either of you could take a stab at
this uh so
i'll let uh you know maybe grant if you
want to go first just to describe the
backstory
how did you guys get to know each other
it's really funny i remember hearing
michael i mean there's a lot happening
in our country right now because it's a
20-year anniversary since the sydney
olympic games so there's plenty going on
and that was michael's first olympics
and
i remember when he got fourth i think in
the the 200 meter fly there
was like a 15 year old on the swimming
pool now swim team where was it fifth
yeah come on man that's close to fourth
though so that's right
right next to it so
i remember just thinking wow what a
freak a 15 year old's gotten fifth i
wonder if we'll ever hear of him again
so and then the next year when he broke
the tournament butterfly world record of
the world championships was that 152 am
i right on that
no i'm 54. i was four six figure yeah
four
six fifty four and nine and in spring
so and then i couldn't believe that a 16
year old actually did that and i got to
you know sort of know michael from from
that moment moving forward and then
you know then we got to train together
and um
i think i i just saw eye to eye on
michael on things like the approach
towards swimming the approach towards
competition
how did you end up training together
just for for those who might say you
know you both sound like you have strong
new jersey accents but
i suspect you're from different places
how did you end up training together
um back in 2003 uh michael and his coach
bob
just came over to australia for a
coaching conference and um
so he spent a few weeks in australia so
we ended up training then and i think
at that point in time we really got to
to know each other and i saw
michael's level of application to
towards his training
and all the new things that he was
trying to bring to the sport like the
underwater off every single wall which
you know for for your listeners tim not
me too many people know
when you're in the middle of a race and
you're at like the 200 300 meter mark
and then you try and push and go
15 meters off the wall it it is one of
the most difficult
things that a person can ever do it's
like a free diver right the last little
bit of holding their breath like
it is tough and and michael started
doing all these sorts of things that i
thought man i wonder if that will
actually work
and um and so i i saw just how creative
and innovative in the sport that he was
and he was just a great guy like he was
just really i just enjoyed hanging out
like we go out to dinner and do things
together and i think um
that the basis of our friendship was
kind of in in 2003 kind of springboarded
from there and every time we saw each
other it meets because we'd obviously be
traveling all the time we just always
connected and
got along well we and we had a lot of
mutual respect for
for each other um and what each other
was bringing to the sport and and also
there was another
you know sort of counterpart of mine ian
thorpe who was through that era and and
i think both michael and i had a lot of
respect for ian so
you know we'd all spend a lot of time
together and um and respect what each
other was doing for the sport at that
time too
and you mentioned i'm going to do a
follow up here
with with you grant then i'm going to
come back to you michael to ask you what
you first
noticed about grant to you grant
when you mentioned innovation and new
things being brought to the sport what
what else
did you notice what were some other
examples that you saw in michael or
through michael
michael is the sort of guy that you
never ever
want to say that he's not going to do
something
you never want to be critical of michael
because he will stick it so far up you
it's not funny
and not many competitors do that if i
actually said something about one of my
competitors
or tried to intimidate them a little bit
not even meaning to
um half the time it would get under
their skin you know it could almost go
into their performance in a negative way
do that to michael and improve his
performance by about 400 percent
very early on even when we play golf
today if
i'm betting on him on the last hole it's
like this intensity of focus
and athletic prowess and everything else
you can imagine that makes you great
just comes into play even if he's had
the worst 17 holes beforehand
so i'll go from a 20 handicap to a zero
in no time and
yeah just on one hole just to stick it
to them
yeah and i keep testing it right because
i'll start jigging them up before that
hole just to see if my theory about him
is correct and
100 of the time i'm proven right
so that's probably one of the other
things about michael and
and you know that's that's an
interesting characteristic that um
i haven't seen in many athletes across a
lot of sports
um that are able to have that ability to
increase performance to that extent
because of maybe a slight bit of
criticism or questioning so that was one
of the other things i really noticed
about him very very quickly
i have some additional questions about
that but i'll i'll hit snooze on those
michael what did you notice about
grant what were your some of your first
impressions
i don't know if you guys are the
listeners can pick up but
i mean as a kid growing up like i was a
massive swimming geek i was a nerd like
i was i was very
into it i was trying to learn anything i
possibly could
but also like i i just respected you
know
other great athletes other great
swimmers and and growing up
idolizing you know some of the greats
that walk before hackie and i
you know i i just i learned so much
history so being able to understand
swimming from a global level very early
on
you know through my sister in a way and
and
i i just really connected with him and
and and as you as you heard with uh with
thorpe as well
those two guys are probably the two
closest swimming friends that i have
to this day you know i feel like i was
closer with with the aussies than i was
really with the americans and and
so it was kind of strange but you know
like i i
i do remember those 2003 days you know
bob and i were going back to uh some of
those old sets a few weeks ago hackie
and
pretty good seeing some of those kicking
sets some of the pulling sets
um the underwater stuff that we were
doing with fins
i mean just everything and and that's
what i mean like
you know there aren't many athletes that
can really take it to that that level
uh back to back days and and you know
that was something i that i saw in hacky
and
and obviously i i respected the hell out
of and um
you know the chance that we got to to
spend together was always very special
always very meaningful and you know
obviously he turned into
you know more of a brother than anything
else and it's been cool to see it's been
oh my gosh unbelievable so many great
stories
i'm a scatter brain so i'm popping all
over the place and i feel like i'm gonna
take some of your questions away so i'll
stop
feel free to bounce around scatterbrain
that i've made an entire career out of
it on this podcast
feel free grant i want to ask you
about intensity and i'm going to do it
in a somewhat sideways fashion but both
of you
are known for being beasts in training
and having just ungodly
work capacities and i don't know if i'm
getting the hours
right please correct me if i'm wrong but
30 to 40 hours of training a week maybe
more
at times i i want you to correct that in
your in your answer if need be but
it seems like the combination of that
volume
plus the intensity that you're both
famous for
would drive anyone into the ground and
i'm just curious
how you prevented that from happening
if maybe you could speak to that grant
yeah i think um you know first and
foremost around the 30 to 40 hours
that's right
we would train anywhere from some kind
of five to seven hours a day
six days a week i know michael would do
seven days a week i think he trained
like 530 540 days straight
um into beijing so he knows all
about his application yeah what was that
a little more than that but it's okay
five five or six straight years yeah so
i mean
that degree of application is one thing
but you're right you you have to be
doing it better
far harder than the guy on the other
side of the world and um
and i think um the goal the outcome was
just so
strong the desire um and i think when
something is so
meaningful and purposeful to to you as
an individual
you're willing to do anything and it's
funny the body does get used to it to an
extent you get used to
getting up at 4 45 you know doing that
eight kilometers doing it to the
intensity that you need to then going
into the gym for 90 minutes doing that
then going back in the afternoon and
doing it all again
so um and it's amazing how much more you
can absorb
than what you give yourself credit for
but one of the things i always tried to
do
is whenever my coach would set something
um like an insanely hard set
and if i finished it i would do one or
two more reps
and he was known as you know having one
of the top three intense programs in the
world
from a lot of the physiologists out
there so i always just try to take it to
the next level every single time i knew
with my event which
probably is different to some of the
finesse that michael had in his events
in terms of his underwater and skills
for me was about
being tough and he's trained with a
great 1500 meter swimmer called eric
vance so he knows
the intensity in the the mindset and i
was very similar to eric in terms of
if you have to pull me out of the water
after this session and put me in an
ambulance i do not care as long as i get
every ounce out of myself and you've got
to show up with that attitude every day
because
that's how tough the guys are that
you're racing and
it's just it's just the way it is and i
think when you get the wins
it keeps you going right it keeps you
going to the next step it makes the
the bits a little bit more digestible
and and i just
love that feeling i just love that
feeling afterwards and uh
and i knew when i rocked up to race day
that if i'd done that work that
no one was ever going to touch me in my
and that and that's like the thing
though because it's like
you know like there are days obviously
you don't want to go grant right like
like every day wasn't perfect for us so
it's like you know like
on those days you have to be able to
find that 10 20
30 50 you know instead of zero where you
could just full-on
punt the whole day the workout skip like
be lazy like do whatever the hell you
wanted to so it's like
you know like to be as consistent as we
both were
like throughout our career literally
every every single session
every single stroke mattered um so
you know like that that's it's like for
the listeners out there like it was
the smallest finest details you could
possibly
think about you know we we had to think
or we
we had to go through and fine-tune daily
like i i almost
talked to it as like uh you're you're
you're going to college and and the top
level is the 10
000 level class or the thousand level
class whatever the hell you want to call
it
you know if you skip a few of those
classes like you're missing key steps
that are going to help you
at the very top level when the lights
are on when
you know you might have had a bad
night's sleep or your roommate might be
sick or maybe the food in the dining
hall wasn't very good
your air conditioning doesn't work you
know so it's like all of the things that
you're doing
daily are prepping you for any kind of
situation that you're gonna
face at the olympics at world
championships whatever your big event is
totally and i suppose that's that's
something that
wasn't in my mind when i asked the
question and that is it's not just about
developing more strength it's not just
about developing the brute attributes
it's also about
the smallest technical details
that you have to train to be second
nature for
competition
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis
you would have missed out on 50 percent
five zero percent of your returns
don't miss out on the best days in the
market stay invested in a long-term
automated investment portfolio
wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
takes about three minutes to sign up and
then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your
risk appetite and manage it for you at
an incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay on your investment
gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today and
you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free
for life that's wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
tim
are there any particular michael tools
or
techniques for recovery that you found
to
really pull their weight so to speak and
have an impact because
as a as a mirror
you know five foot eight uh
meat cube i'm not really built for
hydrodynamics
i think about training as you did
for five to six years straight and i
just
can't imagine a human body withstanding
that without
some portfolio of recovery techniques
was there anything that stands out
i mean we had to be like we had to be on
top of everything you know like trying
to
like i was saying before trying to do
something that no one's ever done before
you know have that give yourself the
chance it's like you you you really have
to approach it in
every single different way possible than
ever has been done before so
you know there is no blueprint for it so
for us it was
you know one step at a time and and for
me to be able to
to swim at such a high level every
single day i i had to be on top of
whether it's nutrition sleeping drinking
water you know like i
i treated my body like i was a ferrari
you know like i treated my body like i'm
a high performance race car because i
i'm asking it to do so many things so
you know i was sleeping
probably eight to ten hours a night with
a two hour nap during the day
i was eating eight to ten thousand
calories a day
ice tub massages uh i had one that like
pt strength conditioning guy for 15
years that was
did all of my massages all of my
stretching all of my graston all of my
cupping
i i had to be super super anal about it
because i i
needed to ask my body to do so many
things every single day so
i guess i'm kind of old school like i i
never really got into cryo or anything
like that but but still to this day
like i i i work out six seven days a
week and and
you know for me to be able to do
everything i need to do from playing
golf
having enough energy with the kids and
and doing everything i need to do
personally
i have to recover so i am stretching
probably 45 minutes a day
i'm probably ice tubbing once maybe
twice a week i go to acupuncturists
cupping
twice a week so you know i i think
lebron said something about it earlier
in the year he spends
a million dollars a year on recovery and
honestly like that just makes sense to
me because
if he's like from what i just said you
know he's asking his body to do so much
at such a high level it's like you you
have to treat it like it like it should
be treated right you know you have to
give it everything it needs
um and and that's the very basic stuff
so i mean i have
all of my stats like blood work sleep
numbers um
lactate numbers anything you can
possibly imagine about
health or recovery i i have it logged
for the last
15 years 20 years of my career so
i i was extremely you know yeah i mean i
was very anal about it because i
i needed to be i was selfish in a way
yeah
that makes all the world of sense and
uh i think i think we're going to come
back to that that focus
and the the pros and cons of it grant
i'd love to ask you
about anything you have found helpful
for
sleep and that that comes to mind
because
michael you just mentioned it you also
mentioned lebron james who's been on
this podcast
and has a number of different techniques
including using
calm app and other technological tools
for helping with getting to sleep did
you find anything
in particular i mean aside from training
many many hours a day which i'm sure
helps
uh for sleep during your training or
post uh competitive career
yeah i always found um you know some of
the apps are great i actually used to
put on one of these apps that used to
just have the rainwater
um coming down and falling on the leaves
and and those sorts of just calming type
of things
um it's really funny to today uh the
best way i find to fall asleep is just
breathing exercises
and and just focusing away from from
everything that you know
kind of matters in your life around work
and you know the things that you're
responsible for that you know normally
keep you awake at night but um
it's it's quite funny um to to michael's
point just around recovery you know
sleep is
is obviously the ultimate thing to to
rest the body and um
i track everything you know i'm sitting
here with you know
one watch on one hand another one on the
other hand i don't even know if either
of them tell the time but
they're tracking my heart rate
variability they're my sleep they're
tracking my recovery
you know and and i check these stats
like there's no tomorrow like i'm still
a professional athlete i think you're
just hardwired to be like that but
you know and it depends what phase
you're going through your career you
know those
points where i had injuries and my
shoulder would just be my shoulders
would be aching
at night so i'd be sitting there with
bags of peas
on my shoulders just to get the
inflammation down and
you know there's so many different sort
of cycles throughout my career where
yeah you'd
have trouble sleeping um sometimes i
would feel that the pressure too much
coming into competitions after time for
some reason and uh
and those are the the difficult times
where you know you need your recovery
more than ever but you're finding it
hard to to be able to get that rest so
you know what's good for one person is
not necessarily good for another but
what i know today
is if i just did a lot more meditation a
lot more things of slowing down a lot
more mindfulness
those are the sorts of things that would
have helped me a lot more throughout
my career because they're great
techniques that i use today and i
probably sleep better today because of
you know just
the foundation of knowledge that i've
been able to build over the time because
we were just so anal and just so focused
on
on recovery and trying to find ways to
go okay
the body is gone how am i gonna get it
back to michael's point that this is not
a tractor
it's a ferrari and if a bolt's a little
bit loose this thing will not perform so
everything has got to be right
i used to have to walk somewhere i would
sit down as soon as i got there just
so my hip flexors wouldn't tighten up
because i wasn't as good a kicker as
what michael was oriented thought so i
had to do everything on my legs i was
better on the upper body um i could do
that i could pull
it's it's called pulling just you know
you sort of tie your legs up and
you know swim with your arms only that
was my strength but my lower wasn't so
i used to just be fixated on that every
minute of the day to make sure whenever
i rocked up to training and particularly
competition
my legs were loose my hip flexors had
full range and
and i was going to get the most out of
them so yeah
it's an obsession and that's the way it
needs to be
yeah i was uh spending some time
grant with one of our mutual friends
who's is uh deep in training
right now and we were hiking and he said
this is great i just can't do too much
hiking and i said why not and he said
because i don't want my ankles
to be overly stable or
strengthened because i need the
flexibility i want the
looseness in the ankles and i was like
wow that's not something i hear every
day
only sport where you want loose angle uh
ankles you you look at tennis players
they've got all the support in place
we're doing the opposite we'll have a
panel of wood where you know you've got
to strap across the top and you chuck
your foot in there
and you're leaning back to try and
create more flexion and angle
and that's the thing like michael and
ian thorpe are incredibly flexible
and incredibly strong and incredibly
mobile
and i didn't have that that last part
around the the mobility that these guys
have because
think about it your feet are like
flippers in the water so if you get that
extra bit of angle and you get that
flick right at the end
it's going to propel you just that
little bit more and
you know i'm sitting here at an olympic
games where i've got
two silver medals i think it's over the
course of about you know
1200 meters of racing and they're by 0.2
of a second in total so
you know every little bit matters
michael i want to revisit
a name that has come up a lot so far in
this conversation and that is
ian thorpe and it ties into
what grant was saying about using
critical or negative or doubting
comments
as rocket fuel for your motivation
in the course of doing homework for this
conversation
i came across a note on wikipedia that
said uh
which quote that he has yes
there's two of them that i remember go
ahead i'm interested to see which one
you have
so wikipedia feel free to correct any of
this it's not it's not so much a direct
quote it just says
thorpe initially said that it would be
highly unlikely for phelps to win eight
gold medals at the 2008
summer olympics in beijing phelps used
the remarks his motivation and taped the
words to his locker during the games
so i just wanted to fact check that is
that true 100
without question yeah what were the
words that you put on your locker
uh you know i think at that time bob and
i were
um you know a lot of a major chunk of my
career i'd say
we we were big on you know highlighting
different
uh quotes or times and you know that
people had done or
um things that we were trying to do so
you know like for me like every morning
i got out of bed and
and i saw my goal sheet of the times i
wanted to do that year
or at the olympics or whatever written
down so when i was getting out of bed i
was getting out of bed with a purpose
um so then when i got to the pool that's
where that
quote was just honestly if i if i was
kind of having an off day
i used that as as hacky said a little
extra fuel
um that was something that if somebody
did say it was impossible
i was gonna shove that so far up that i
was gonna make them eat their words no
matter what
um like that was the the there was no if
ends but about it
and again in 2016 i believe he said
uh something along the lines of it'll be
impossible or uh almost impossible to
see
somebody over the age of 30 win an
individual gold medal
and funny enough i i was giving him [ __ ]
about it after the olympics uh
in 16 and and he goes i know how you
work
he said so i i was helping you give that
you know
get that extra fuel to really give you
some extra motivation to
to really make sure you kick some ass so
um
you know he you know because like to
grant's point though like i i knew grant
probably better than any other athlete
in the world i knew sort be better than
any other athlete in the world and and
you know the same way for them you know
like we we just we knew about each other
because we we we all were just
trying to learn whatever we could and
use it into
our our everyday lifestyle to help us
accomplish the goals that we wanted
and two to ian's credit or defense
i'll i will read one of the actual
quotes that is in wikipedia
in which he says quote i'm really proud
of him not just because he won eight
golds rather it's how much he has grown
up and matured into a great human being
never in my life have i been so happy to
have been proved wrong
so ultimately was proved wrong
and as we're talking about this
translation
of using the negative or the critical
into rocket fuel like you said granted
is
at least in my experience which is very
limited but it's rare to see
the one other exception that i can think
of
and and maybe you guys will have uh have
seen this
is michael jordan in the last dance
where
every episode there is an example of
this and
someone will say something to him and
then they'll say [ __ ]
shouldn't have done that and he comes
back and breaks
some universal record in the next
quarter
and it was so remarkably consistent
and yet when you flash forward
and you are watching this this current
day footage
of michael you can't help but get the
feeling that he is still very
angry but he has lost a target at which
he can direct this anger and so i'm
curious to hear
from you michael because i've lived in
my life with a lot of anger
and have you found that to cut both ways
what has been your experience with anger
during the competitive years or
afterwards uh
i mean naturally heck you can agree i i
carry a lot of uh a lot of anger uh and
and a lot of that i would say stems from
my childhood and you know some of the
things that i experienced
but i also think anger is is
really really what what did fuel me on
those days where
i just didn't want to swim you know
those those were the biggest things
it was almost like turning a switch on
in a way you know i i'll say now
knowing what i know about depression
knowing what i know about
anxiety mental health and and about
myself
as well i i know that i can't approach
my life or anything that i do in my life
like i did in swimming
just because i i guess i could say i was
a professional or i was a doctor or
whatever the hell you want to call
me in in the swimming world but like i
understood swimming
you know i'd like to think almost better
than anybody and you know definitely a
feel for it so
you know i i don't have enough practice
doing
what i'm doing now in life so you know i
i do
have to take steps back and and take
deep breaths or
you know i i found that through covid my
wife and i's communication
level has gone up another level you know
so it's like little things like that
for me i i'm constantly learning more
and more about myself
and about why i am how i am so
yeah do i still get angry of course but
i play a lot of golf i
you know as i said i work out six or
seven days a week i'm
i lift weights three days a week i um
for
anywhere 60 to 90 minutes and then the
other four days
i'm either swimming i am riding a
stationary bike
or i am on uh an elliptical
so you know those are kind of outlets
for me but
it does get scary at times and you know
i will say hacky has always been there
for me
through any single moment of my life um
through those dark times you know but i
i can also say you know
during this quarantine it you know it's
been difficult for me
um you know i i've been very open about
that recently and
and through all of this and and you know
i can imagine that it's been difficult
for more and more people and and
you know i'll say the one thing you know
to the listeners out there who are
listening to it
you're not alone you know that's the one
thing i i truly truly want to repeat
you'll hear me say it a lot of times to
this podcast but
you know you you are definitely not
alone with your thoughts your emotions
but
if you are afraid or you're scared or
nervous
reach out to somebody for help a trained
therapist or a trained doctor
um this is it's just a very uncertain
time for everybody in the world so
that was a little rant so go ahead i
enjoy
rants that's why we have a long format
you mentioned dark times i'd like to
talk about this because i i feel like
both of you have been
very open about this which is a huge
service i mean it is a huge public
service to people who feel alone and
it's a huge
public service to people who feel like
they are uniquely flawed
or are in a place of shame because
the mental health and depression and so
on
can be very stigmatized still
michael could you speak to when you knew
you needed help
or when you hit rock bottom could you
just tell the story
of uh that moment or moment
the first time i experienced depression
i'd say was back in 2004
you know coming back after all that
great success and
you know obviously you expect it to to
continue and
you know you get back and it's good for
you know a week or so and then you
kind of feel like you fall off the face
of the earth so for me it was
it was just beginning to open and talk
about these things honestly like i felt
there was a
weight lifted off my shoulders you know
these were things that
i i carried for you know probably 20
years 15 years and and
um you know when when i really do get
into those dark times i
i basically isolate myself and and give
everybody the heisman because i
i i almost feel like i am causing
more stress to their life or i'm a
burden or this that or the other so like
i
i go strictly internal and almost like i
pick at scabs or like
like internal scabs that you know really
hurts like i almost try to inflict pain
but
not literally inflict pain so it it it
gets bad and and when it does get bad it
really spirals
and i'll say one thing hackie hackie was
over here
was that two years ago happy yeah two
two years ago yeah 2018.
yeah i mean that was that was one of the
scariest ones that you know i've really
experienced
and and i honestly i feel like i'm alone
i feel like everybody's attacking me
and yeah it's just it's an uncomfortable
feeling but
you know i i basically i guess the
easiest way for describing it would be
like a
a turtle going back into its shell i
want more than anything to feel like
i am a human being because i i feel like
that's what i am
you know i i feel like yeah you know i
had a great talent and
you know i put my mind to something and
[ __ ] i didn't give up i went through ups
and downs and
you know i was able to accomplish some
pretty amazing goals but
you know at times like i feel like i'm
you know almost a piece of meat and an
object and you know i think especially
during those times when i start going
there
you know when when i'm in dark times and
start going there it just it's just
downward spirals
so that's why you know i i alluded
earlier to talking about you know how
much my
my mind and my wife's communication has
really just grown
through quarantine because i would say i
had a similar incident
you know like i had in 2018 where you
know it was very scary and
and you know i know nicole was doing you
know everything she could to help and
you know we were almost forced to grow
and to change as a couple
because of the current situation and and
um the situation at the time it was
difficult but honestly like
that's the coolest thing for me that
that i am so excited about with
having depression or with having anxiety
you know because it it
it honestly makes me who i am and and
you know it's i i understand it's never
going to be fixable
and and it's a part of me for the rest
of my life but you know what i think
it's it's something that i want to learn
more about and something i'm excited to
wake up
every day and have that chance to learn
more about so
um you know like that's why i'm so you
know i've
spoken about my wife and i just just
communicating so much more it's it's
crazy to
to even think that that was possible um
but just going over leaps and bounds you
know just
learning more and more about how we both
work and and
things we need to be careful of so we
don't trigger one another it's been a
almost a blessing in disguise for us if
i could
just jump back to one thing that you
said whatever you need please always
and if i'm if i'm misquoting please
please correct me but for those who are
familiar
could you describe what made 2018
scary what was the experience uh i mean
in 2018 i actually took a pair of golf
shoes and i hit myself in the head with
them
that was that was one of the very last
times that i tried to inflict pain on
myself
and and i knew at that point like that
was like that right there
i've never done something like that i've
never even thought about doing something
like that and the fact that i did
that right there was was was a message
for me it was a you know it was a red
flag so
you know coming back to the house and
and you know i had a kind of a meltdown
but you know with grant talking to grant
talking to
you know my wife you know like that was
that was just a learning experience like
they're
like for me like i basically am you know
a pot of water like
at the at the very last second i'm ready
to blow and when i blow
it's pretty bad and it gets pretty ugly
you know i was
i would say throughout my career i'm
great at compartmentalizing i
i would say i could probably win a few
more gold medals at that
um but that's not something to be proud
of so um
you know so so i think like you know
that's that's one thing that i've
learned
you know to just just to really talk
about you know i i've learned more about
my emotions
um and and if i have something i don't
like i i talk about it or i ask
questions about it you know so i think
you know with the experiences that i've
gone through and the struggles that i've
gone through
i feel like i have almost let my guard
down in a way
you know if that kind of makes sense you
know like like drop my shoulders like
taking a deep breath
and and you know just tried to relax you
know because i think
throughout my whole entire life i've
been trying to shave hundreds of a
second off my time right and
and now it for for everyday life i'm i'm
trying to slow it down
so it's it's crazy now for me to look at
life so it's it's
yeah the the last four years have been
interesting but but that in
2018 you know that that to this day
was one of the scariest times of my life
that and 2014 after my second dui
we talked about sleeping earlier and i
have
opened up more and more about this story
just because it's
it's a part of me so basically
throughout a whole entire life
throughout my entire life i i
most of my uh swimming career i we were
prescribed
ambien for traveling for trips you know
to try to acclimate to times and
and that night after my dui i was happy
that i only had
two ambien left that was a sleep aid
that i had and who knows what would have
happened if i had more
you know i think those two moments for
me are are
the two scariest moments of my life and
and you know recently
you know i'd say within the last handful
of weeks like i've
i've had a couple real scary breakdowns
where you know i almost really start
shaking
because i i just don't know what to do i
yeah
i don't know how to control anything and
um
i i yeah that's about it
thank you for sharing michael uh yeah
but it's like you know like like
honestly for for me yes it is
uh it's it's wild to think about it's
wild to talk about but you know
it's it's what makes me me and and you
know hell if i can learn
from just understanding why why i am
certain ways or why i react certain ways
then i feel like i'm setting myself up
to be a better person
and at the end of the day that's all i
want i i want to learn more
you know you've heard us talk about
stats numbers like i want to know stats
i want to know numbers i want to know
why
like i just i don't know why why why to
every single question that you can
possibly think about
so you know like i i just i always know
there are so many other options out
there and and you know if i come to a
dead end
i can reach out to one of those options
or or you know i can backtrack a few
steps and
and take a different route and so yeah
you know i i think
really trying to simplify life and
trying to slow things down for me is
probably
those are the two things that that i
would say i focus on
on a daily daily basis yeah just to just
to give myself a chance
yeah and uh grant i'm going to come
back to you in in just a minute because
i want to
do a similar expedition into
some of the dark chapters to hear your
stories
before we get to that i am looking at
just a paragraph from an espn article
that includes you michael
and i want to read a small portion of it
and ask a question so here's the portion
it says in treatment phelps earned the
nickname preacher mike because each day
began with a chapter of the
purpose-driven life a book given to him
by former baltimore ravens linebacker
and good friend
ray lewis i don't know if you would
still recommend this book or how you
feel about it but are there any
books or resources that you have found
particularly helpful in your journey
in experiencing these things so i have a
a very close friend of mine uh who you
know i asked i feel very comfortable
opening
opening up to and asking a lot of
questions about um i think you know
you know what i'm talking about hockey
uh he he passes me a bunch of different
books and and
some of the ones recently i guess like i
i i was never somebody who liked to read
books and and
when rey gave me that book i wasn't
i wasn't spiritual in any way like i had
you know i wasn't religious
but you know i think through my journey
i i
100 am spiritual without question there
is a power that's greater than me i
don't know what it is
you know but but through my journey i
feel like i have learned so much
from the books that i have received the
purpose-driven life is
one amazing one um the power of now is
an amazing one
um ego is the enemy is one that i go
back to a lot
the subtle art of not giving a [ __ ] is a
great one
um i i loved uh it takes what it takes
i thought that was a great one just
little thing like little books like that
where
where i can you know for me when
whenever i'm listening like i
i tend to do audibles and and you know
when i am listening to it i really just
it's what we all we're all supposed to
do but i i love just taking little small
pieces that
that are similar to things that i did in
my career you know like for me to be as
efficient as i was in swimming i i had
to learn
the absolute bottom line of every single
stroke right like i had to be as
efficient as i could with my body that i
was given so
it's like i've almost done that in ways
it's opened my mind and some
really interesting new thoughts it's
giving me you know new journeys to
travel down
you know roads to go down but yeah i
mean i i would say i i
cycle through a lot of those depending
on
uh as you heard before the the dark
moods that i'm in
i went back to the subtar out of not
giving a [ __ ] just because i
i felt like i was just attacking myself
too much and
and i i just needed to get a handle of a
few things and and
do what i'm teaching my kids you know
take a lie in breath take a deep breath
every once in a while and relax
you know it's not it's not you know it's
not about racing the clock in every
single thing that you do in your life
um so that's one one big big key thing
for me is just
trying to be as simple as in every form
of life as i possibly can and and
it's honestly it's it's looking at my
kids and that's the greatest example
you know i mean we were talking about it
earlier my my two oldest boys were
playing with a metal trash can the other
day you know one of the trash cans where
you step on it the lid pops up
one of them is banging one is banging on
the top like it's a drum the other one
is stomping on the lid and i was like
boomer what are you guys doing
and without missing a beat he looks over
and said dad i've never seen one of
these things before
and like i couldn't do anything but
start laughing so i was like all right
yeah whatever like
go ahead like meanwhile there's a
hundred different noises going on
um and like my i mean i was going crazy
but i i just i laughed like i met i damn
near fell on the ground laughing i was
like that's what kids are like they're
they are the best example of really
living in the moment and it's it's you
know
for me i feel like having having the
time that i have around
around my kids during this quarantine
like i i feel like i i've
i have a few things that i can kind of
log into the memory bank and go back to
when boomer is pressing that red button
that i hate to be pressed inside of me
and he's trying to get my nerves
and and go crazy on me so but kids are
kids and and honestly i i've seen
the and one of the coolest things is
they want to be
us so bad and honestly they they just
love us and and
you know it's it's uh you know for me
told you
i told you we'd get tears um
for me honestly it's taken some of the
dark times that i've been through um
you know just you know just literally
being crying and and having your kids
come up and give you a hug
like those things like that right there
um
you know it's the greatest thing on the
planet so
yeah like there i mean it's just been
it's been a treat and
and uh yeah as a dad it's it's the
greatest feeling in the world
thank you michael
uh grant we're gonna go back into the
depths here
a bit i was gonna say if you want to
keep if you want to keep going you can
it doesn't bother me
i just need a second to wipe the tears
off then i'm good
i've already been through a whole lot of
emotions just listening to that just
going back to you know 2018 and that day
when you know michael was you know not
michael
or or was michael you know just the the
other side of success you know so i just
think um
you know it was tough to to listen to
that i actually had water in my eyes
just listening to it because it was um
you know seeing one of your best mates
um that you've known for so long and
been through everything together um
just go through that it was it was
brutal it was really really tough
sounds brutal what if what have your
personal experience
what did the dark times look like for
you or
are there any particular instances that
come to mind
in terms of knowing when you needed help
or hitting rock bottom
the first thing i'll say um at the
outset it's it's really funny as
as an athlete you you were told from day
one i mean i started swimming when i was
four
and being competitive when i was five
like so everything
throughout my childhood and throughout
my sporting career was
hey if there's an obstacle go through it
overcome it beat it you're injured
you're sick
whatever just turn into a gladiator and
just keep going forward that is your job
so and it was almost like adversity was
your friend and you used to i call the
expression now
with mental health it's like i got used
to i'm fisting my way through difficult
periods
in life and that's not right that's
great as an athlete that's a great
attribute to have to push through pain
and
overcome those challenges to get the
outcome but but in life that actually
doesn't work and i found that out the
hard way and i
realized how real mental health was
so i think you know for for me i i
remember
i've you know been through the ups and
downs and i really never recognized that
about myself because i just kind of
thought okay just put your boots back on
and keep going but
you know a few years ago when you know i
went through a a
really public divorce here in australia
and uh everything that followed from
that
and innuendo and speculation and and you
know people questioning your value set
um just undid me and i just didn't
realize how much it undid me and how
much it took me down and
you know got to a point where you know
in early 2017
you know just kind of one more thing
it's one more thing where i was sitting
in a hotel room
completely isolated two security guards
on that floor so
no one would come near my room you know
sitting on the front page of the
newspaper and the news just
what's going on with me and and then i i
think
the four days that i had there and i was
texting michael at the time i literally
had over a thousand messages
in my phone on whatsapp on my email and
on my sms
within about a three hour time frame and
i think i i got back to
three people and michael was one of them
um and allison schmidt
who um you know live with michael too uh
we're the only people that i got back to
and i think i'd use words like oh i'm
just scared
and everyone thinks you're invincible
for what you've done but you know like
everybody else you just have those
vulnerabilities and when it's so
public it just exaggerates the situation
and amplifies it and creates another
layer of complexity that you have to
deal with and
i just made a commitment to myself i
think at the end of that that i'm never
going to allow myself
to get to this spot again like any time
that i i feel like
you know you're getting pushed to that
edge or things are going wrong
i'm just going to adopt the strategies
that i now know instead of denial
because i would always put myself in
denial i wouldn't let myself
be vulnerable and even my fiance
charlene now like if i start talking
about the way i'm feeling
in isolation i'm going through a
stressful period and she goes oh
she is so proud of me she goes i just
love it when you're vulnerable and i
said uh
i feel like a bit of a [ __ ] to be
honest but yeah cool
and so it's like you know and then i'm
like wow i feel better afterwards
you know that that open and honest
transparency and my relationship is
better
as well so it's like well doing doing
this vulnerability thing which was the
number one thing that i found i had to
tap into going through those stages in
life and phases
um whenever they embark upon upon you
and they come across
at the weirdest times too like even when
things are great and going well
sometimes that's
it can be a low point um after that you
have to deal with that so
yeah i mean i made that decision back in
2017. i basically lived with michael
most of that year
um and he was he was my biggest
supporter
um and you know when i went and did you
know therapy and got some help he was a
guy you know drove me there and dropped
me off and
we had talks till 2 3 a.m sometimes you
know later in the morning and
he'd come in and wake me up in the
morning with the dogs and boomer
crawling on the bed all over me which i
really appreciated but
you know it's it's those sorts of times
where you know
we'll just always be there for each
other but people see us as these people
who've achieved great things and won
multiple olympic gold medals and
world records and all that sort of stuff
but yeah just because you're good at
something doesn't mean that you don't
you know fall into the same fate as
everybody else when it comes to
to mental health or just being a human
and um
yeah i had to learn those things
definitely the hard way
you were mentioning the the
vulnerability
with your significant other i was just
having a conversation last week
with a coach who you could really
consider on some level a therapist
and he said to me candor is the ultimate
aphrodisiac
and uh it seems it seems to have a lot
of
benefits not just singular benefits and
you mentioned strategies i'd love to
hear what other
rules or strategies you have found or
developed for yourself
so that when you s when you sense
yourself edging towards
the brink you are better able
to reel yourself away from it
i think um just doing everything
proactively
i i exercise like michael you know six
six days a week i try and make myself
have a recovery day
um which is hard when you've got
personalities like ours um we don't
we know the importance of recovery but
we just like to keep going and going and
going
uh so that's one thing the other thing
that i do it's funny i went to stop you
know sort of drinking
um for a year and then i got to a year
and i was kind of like you know what i
don't even feel like drinking anymore it
kind of
um and it's not like i was ever a person
who drank every day by any means it
would be far and few between but i could
go
go hard if we were you know having a
night with the boys or something like
that
or use it to escape so you know i i
stopped drinking so
full stop like i got to a year and i was
like you know what i don't even feel
like that
anymore it's not something in my life
that i value or i like or it brings
value to me
so um i don't do that i also
make sure that i get enough sleep um
that's really important
for me that's i eat very healthy um you
know diet
has been a big part and just that that
whole sort of health regime that i have
to follow just to make sure that i'm in
a good space so and the one thing that i
still find difficult that i do and you
know we just touched on is i talk about
it
i talk about where i'm at how i'm
feeling why i'm feeling like that
instead of bottling it up
um michael and i we're the kings of
compartmentalizing things
and actually just locking them away i'll
deal with that box when i need
to deal with that box but unfortunately
that box is growing and being fueled
and when it goes and it's not good it's
not good at all and michael and i know
it is best
so i i try and jump into that box and i
try and work through it try and get it
out and and
and so i i think for me it's it's all
that sort of proactive stuff that i'm
doing that
and and i feel more settled in my my
life now than i ever have and you know
what
and i know this with nicole because i
know you know michael's wife
extremely well and and the the wonderful
human being that she is
um just how good she is for michael in
that situation how much he cares and
loves him like
it's actually beautiful to watch it
makes me you know i
because i've been through this stuff
with her you know like and you know
we've
spoken about how we we're there for
michael and you know charlene's the same
for me like
i just that partnership of someone who
gets you like she gets me
she gets my my drive and ambition and
and yet that that other mental
you know sort of fault that you whatever
you want to call it vulnerability
those things that that are imperfect she
gets that and she likes it and works
with me on it and and
so i think uh i haven't necessarily had
the right partnerships in life as well
so i think tim that's a really important
part of who you're surrounding yourself
by but that that significant other
can make and break in many respects too
because they've got to connect with a
unique personality which i know michael
and i certainly um share uniqueness like
that
so you know they're they're kind of the
the things that really matter and i
look it's been a journey to to get to
know all those things because i've made
so many mistakes along the way but
i just know what makes me feel like more
of me now and feels like a purpose
and and the things that you know help
support and maintain that
grant do you see a someone like a
therapist on a regular basis or
are they used only in cases of emergency
or beginning to redline
i do if i've gone through you know a
hard sort of period i i won't say on a
consistent sort of week-to-week
month-to-month basis
um but if i am going through a stressful
period i've definitely got that support
network there and and i'll jump online
um have a talk get it out um because
sometimes it's it's and i've learned
this too i didn't have really used a
sports psychologist too much when i was
swimming because i always thought you
know i was invincible
so and that was a weakness if i had to
pop into that
um little did i know that would have
really helped me and i might have had a
a better trophy cabinet than what i've
got if i if i recognize that at the time
but now
sometimes family members i know i spoke
about significant other than but i know
family members sometimes aren't
necessarily the ones you should be
tapping into because the emotion is just
too close so
having someone a little bit more
objective has the skill set has the
understanding someone you can have a
different type of conversation with is
really important so
definitely got that network in there tap
into it when you know
that the flags kind of come up what are
the flags like when do you know it's
time to take yourself
in for a 60 000 mile checkup with
a professional what are some of the
signs that that you notice
i mean we spoke about anger before
michael you know was was talking about
that and the way
he's able to channel it and look there's
a negative connotation with anger
because it's not always a bad thing
sometimes anger can
push you to get more out of yourself to
deliver an outcome that is amazing
you know so but sometimes it can when
you're kind of
you're edgy you're irritable you're
you know you're not sleeping well you
know the things just aren't
escaping the mind i think all those kind
of
you know little red flags that sort of
start to add up and compound and you're
just not removing that that stress that
weight they're kind of the things that
you start to to recognize and go hey
i'm going through a bit of you know this
this is not just a one-off right now
this is not a two-off this is kind of
been a little bit more sustained than
what i would like and i think i
have a much greater ability to check in
with that now
than what i've ever had where before it
would be like that little box that i
said it goes into or just let's just
stuff it back in there with the others
and i don't let that happen anymore so
yeah it's just
it's it's mood more than anything else
and if it's a sustained poor mood then
yeah that's that's the thing that i go
okay we've got to do something about
this or
you know i i i in a situation where i've
got
twins from a previous marriage and and i
miss them like crazy when they're not
here
and and the impact that that had on me
for so many years that i
failed to even really talk about has
been a big thing that i just highlight
now and i'll just go to shelly and i'm
just like i'm really you know missing
jagger or charlize or you know and i'll
just start to talk about it
and then all of a sudden you know you
kind of get on the other side of that so
they're kind of the things that i
recognize now that that aren't
as big as blind spots as they were
previously and when you talk to
a professional if you do what does the
format look like
is it more about really just getting it
off your chest and talking to someone
or is there a particular type of
guidance
or a format that is helpful to you
i i have a guy who i tap into and he's
almost got
um a comical element to the his style
which i really connected with
so i i love that because he's
extremely intelligent very very bright
and look i'll write down the things that
i'm feeling
and that that i feel like i've got to
really check in with and get
through and ask questions about so i'll
do that so that's the structure i come
in with
he'll then just pull out stuff on all of
that that just
makes it um takes the emotion out of it
almost it almost goes
it's more pragmatic he goes you know
this is why that would happen this is
why you feel like that
you know what you're kind of
catastrophizing that that's not as big
as you seem like
and then you'll make you know
comparisons and perspectives uh
around other people or other situations
and it kind of gives you a different
view
and it's like he just comes in and
provides these additional lenses that i
didn't have
that he's just given me and i kind of
cover off all the topics like that and
then and we have a laugh
through it all too once you kind of get
on the other side of each of those areas
and and so i find that that style um
has really worked with me it's a good
question tim no one's ever actually
asked me that before
well you know if i can get one novel
question and
i'll be quite pleased with myself
you guys have been interviewed 500
million times so i'm glad to
to give myself a pat on my bald head for
that one and i'll
i'll follow it up because you mentioned
something that i find very interesting
and that is sending something in written
form to this
therapist beforehand is it a stream of
consciousness i'm feeling this
because of this and that is it just like
one gigantic paragraph or page
or is it something else that just seems
like such a time saver to provide that
context
to someone in advance so they can
actually put some
some thought into how they might respond
to you i think you
i mean you probably got this sense
through the chat you know michael and i
we're very analytical we think through
everything in every situation and every
outcome that's the reason why
we know you know every time with respect
to our events and you know the timeline
and history of our sport so well
and and i think if i'm going to approach
something i might as well do it properly
and get the absolute most i can out of
it so
it's just dot points um dot points and
specific areas like things that have
been on my mind
situation start points dot points are
bullet points i guess yeah
yeah in aussie term yes so yeah that's
good
i can i can just say for all of that
stuff for you thank you
i'm fluent it's good when i go over and
stay with michael
um we'll go out and i'll say something
and he'll repeat it for me and i was
like
yeah what he said because no one
everyone sort of looked at me like i've
got two heads
but michael's the ultimate at
deciphering aussie slang
um yeah so so bullet points is exactly
what i jot down yeah dark points
yeah so yeah and so for me that that
works
they kind of just i cover the areas the
topics that have been on my mind or the
situation not normally it's more of a
situation for me
day to day i'm pretty good it's it's
more if i've come across something
that's
sustained stress or i can't work through
myself
and look at to be honest that seems to
be happening a little bit less in my
life but to say
in saying that i know it could intensify
at any point in time and i recognize
that you've got to
always stay on top of those things and
it's been great for the work that i do
now and
and the life that i have and the dad
that i am i think i've just improved
across so many different areas and
and it's probably where i refer back to
sport i'm like damn i wish i used that
sports psychologist
a lot more and tapped into that i i
didn't even recognize vulnerability for
for a split second throughout
basically my entire career and i feel
like that was a bit of a disaster now
and it actually probably would have set
me up um better for for post sport
career as well
well it seems like a lot of super powers
have
on the other side of the coin super
weaknesses almost by definition right
because if you have
if you have a hyper focus on anything in
life
by definition you have to neglect other
things you cannot
you only have so much attention to slice
and dice
right and if you're using
compartmentalization
as one of the tools for
optimizing as a competitor which every
competitor i've interviewed on this
podcast seems
to be very good at then uh
sort of a price associated with that
when it's uh when it's applied
more broadly speaking michael do you do
you
meet with therapists or professionals on
a regular basis
i'm online all the time i mean with
everything with traveling as much as i
do
i spend a lot of time on talk space i
i've
worked with talk space for a few years
now and
and honestly for as much time as we're
on our smartphones it's
just kind of a no-brainer but but also
besides that like like the hackies point
i'll be the first one to admit i still
compartmentalize a little bit
but i'll say i don't think i would make
the podium anymore
if i was competing in it so i i think
i've definitely improved but
my big thing is just i i i pile things
up sometimes and and
like i can't agree with what hackie said
uh and and what you were saying as well
tim like
when we did that in our career like like
i was almost selfish in
in a way where i everything i was doing
in my life was based around swimming
every single decision i made
and now with the family it's it's not
that way my life is different so
i have to take a step back and almost
reassess everything that's what i was
saying like
you know really simplifying everything
to the the smallest form because that's
that's what grant and i you know did
during our career and honestly like i
was sitting here taking
you know notes listening to you know
kind of what grant was grant does when
he
you know kind of feels himself you know
spinning
i literally was like oh my gosh that's
exactly what i had to do if i wanted to
learn
underwater dolphin kick or you know like
i had to break it down to the simplest
form so you know that like that's really
what i have to do more and
you know give myself you know a little
bit more credit from time to time where
i'm as hard on myself as i am you are
the toughest person in yourself that i
know oh like brutal bro like
bro i'm sitting here looking at like i
mean i can't even
i got some of these names that i have on
my desk i'm not i'm not going to
repeat but i mean hackie like you know
like i also like
to hacky's point like i love writing
stuff down writing stuff down to see
you know like especially with dates you
know because times for me are so
important so
if i know i'm going through a dark phase
like what was i writing like why was i
thinking these things so
you know like here like i've felt alone
or i felt dark
lately um so those are things that i
have written on my calendar so like
if i sit down i see that and i'm like
why was i feeling dark like i have so
much to be
you know happy for i have so much to be
proud of like there's so many amazing
things
going on in this world with me with my
life with everything like why am i dark
why am i afraid why do i feel
worthless almost so you know like i i
feel like writing stuff down
really helps and like that's why like
for for listeners out there in
particular like if you guys
find ways to simplify things because we
we live in over
a crazy crazy moving fat crazy
fast-moving world where
you know there there's always things
trying to get our attention so if we can
simplify things and focus on what's
important to us
you know i think it just it makes our
life easier right like there's there's
less stress to worry about
so and and you hear hackie like hacky
talk like communicating
[ __ ] i made the joke that i learned how
to communicate at the age of 30.
yeah it's it's i mean i can laugh about
it because i like
i was really good at compartmentalizing
but like that's not good
so you know like that that's that's why
i like
i talk so much about this this
quarantine and and
you know how much it's forced us to
become vulnerable in a way
because there's so much unknown so it's
like if we want to give ourselves a
chance then we have to do something
different so
you know if it's opening up and talking
about something that is scary
try it you know because like i'll say
like all this stuff that that
you know i've i've talked about you know
throughout that that happened throughout
my career
i mean should i carry that thing like
all that stuff along for 10 years
so you know like having that out and and
open
not it one makes it so much easier to
talk about but two
it like there's there's so much less
weight on my shoulders
i feel i feel normal you know like like
talking about this stuff that
i know there are so many other people
that go through the same thing
are in similar different ways like like
i i just i i don't know like i just
i feel so much better like my shoulders
drop and
and that's just something that i will
always say and try to push
well there's a weight there's a weight
to secrets
or keeping things inside or there can be
and it makes me also
want to mention that there is a new
documentary
hbo documentary out called the weight of
gold in which you're featured very
heavily
why be part of that and i think we've
probably
mentioned a lot of the reasons why but
and maybe a better question because
that's kind of a lazy question i should
know better
better question is how does it feel
having done that and then maybe you can
describe it it feels yeah yeah yeah
please please please say more and and
just for those who don't have any
context
the weight of gold is an hbo sports
documentary
very very well shot exploring the mental
health challenges that olympic athletes
often face
i just wanted to provide that since i
didn't explain it but could you could
you expense
say more about
as you've heard or as people have seen
or read i i've struggled you know
throughout my whole career so
you know in 2016 where i was probably
you know more aware of just life in
general and everything that was going
on more than i ever have in my life so
you know at that point i
i saw that there were other athletes
that were going through
similar things like i was you know going
through opening ceremonies and seeing
athletes
you know almost body language like i i
feel like that's something that i've
learned
to read really well over over you know
throughout my life but
i started like reading people but i also
started hearing
things that people were saying you know
seeing things that people were posting
or this or that and i was like oh like
literally
i said oh [ __ ] this is a lot bigger than
i thought you know because i i always
knew it was
you know mental health in general was
something that was very big
but i almost like it i i felt like it
smacked me in the face at the 2016
olympics and
and you know losing way too many of our
family members in the olympic world
uh over the last five years like i i
want to cry every time i think about it
so
you know you mean to suicide committing
suicide yes
so for me to be able to do this
documentary with the athletes that we
had
who were so vulnerable i honestly i
can't thank them enough for
opening up and and you know being them
being their authentic self and and
filling i guess sharing some stories
about you know what we experience and
what we go through but
you know as we stated earlier this is
something you know there's a massive
stigma
around mental health and this is
something that that you know a journey
that i've started on and
and i'm breaking the wall down as fast
as i can
um and and you know the more that people
stand up and talk about their stories
and their struggles we're gonna break it
down piece by piece and and
you know doing this documentary i feel
is an awesome first step and
and you know just kind of a raw look at
some of the things that go through our
heads and and that we experience and
we're not this this statue you know we
we are a human being
and it was something yeah like i said i
i can't say enough i'm super proud of
it it just shows just
like i'm i'm i was a kid in a candy
store working on it
um this is something it's it's you know
it's like my baby so you know i've
you know i guess really since i opened
up in 2014 about my struggles with
depression and
anxiety you know i i you know really
kind of
took it by the horn so to say and and
you know this is my mission like i'm
going to do
everything i can one to learn as much as
i can about mental health but also
you know try to help as many people as i
can break this wall down
the suicide number is continuing to
climb and it frustrates the hell out of
me i mean i i read a story last night
going to bed of two brothers that that
are on a show over in london
and honestly i i just i my heart hurts
because
i i feel some of the pain that they go
through and
i mean i think the biggest thing i i
want people to know that there is help
on the other side
you know i've been and i've seen a lot
of really dark places throughout my life
but
you know i i also know that i'm not
alone so
when i look at that word on my on my
desk like that i wrote down like i am
not alone
but that's that's part of my darkness
and and you know i think just
always always knowing that that that
there is somebody out there that that's
what we all have to realize
um no matter what we're going through
somebody is there to
hold your hand to give you a hug to you
know whatever it is that you need
because we we we are not alone in life
and and honestly we can't do
anything in life by ourselves like it's
really hard if you think about it
you know and and if we can include other
people that that love us and and want to
be around us then it makes life 10 times
better
that was one thing that i had to learn
the hard way with compartmentalizing
throughout my career is is
i couldn't do it by myself it was
impossible i couldn't handle the
the stress the of the emotions and the
feelings all that stuff that was
building up inside of me while i'm
trying to perform at the absolute best
like it's
it's impossible it's unhealthy so uh you
know i think that's that's the biggest
thing
you know really being able to do it and
put it together and you know i was i was
honestly frustrated with
how long i mean i'm somebody that wants
stuff done
fast so you know i never realized how
long the process
yeah right so i i never really realized
how
long the process of making a piece like
that takes and
and to be honest i'm extremely thankful
that that
it it came out and we were able to
launch it
during covent because it's it's the
single you know that was the one thing
that i was deathly afraid of when when
everything started happening was
the the impact on everyone's mental
health that this was going to take
and and we've seen suicide numbers
increase so
you know i i can't stress enough how
important it is to you know
you have something going on inside of
you that's not normal
say something to somebody write it down
something don't hold on to it you know i
think
life is life is definitely too damn
short and you know as as i said earlier
i want to slow down time as much as i
can
and and be able to enjoy everything that
that that life has to offer
totally and one way of slowing down time
is sharing time
with others and it's and it strikes me
that of course on one level
i respect both of you tremendously as
just icons of competition as
as champions of achievement
but what impresses me even more than
that
is the model of male friendship
and brotherhood and mutual support that
you guys
have demonstrated uh certainly privately
but also
publicly and i'm just so happy to have
both of you
on this call because that seems
so foundational to your
success as not athletes necessarily
although that could be part of it but
as humans is having that deep bond and
mutual support and like you said michael
even if you are out there and feel alone
which is very easy
during covet and it's easy all the time
in modern industrialized cultures
because
we are very much compartmentalized
physically and separated from
a lot of interaction and cohabitation
and so on
there are tools like talk space there
are
professionals who are available and just
reaching out to someone
can release so much pressure in the
system
and there are options so i feel like the
weight of gold
as a dock coming out now is is
great timing during very bad times
for for millions of people so i couldn't
agree more
and grant i realized i did not come back
and ask you one of the questions that
i'd asked michael which was
related to books or resources
that you've found helpful my audience is
always interested in books
certainly any resources or tools but are
there any books
that come to mind for you that were
either particularly helpful
with respect to challenging times or
books overall that you've
recommended or gifted the most to other
people
oh i think i gave this set a lot to
michael so that was
that was one one which was that
uh the satellite of not giving a [ __ ] so
oh yes yeah yeah mark matson
yeah yeah so that one i i just reread
that probably a couple of months ago
that that book always just takes me back
one or two steps and reuse my
perspective on situations because
you know i'm i'm a hyper focused
individual
when i get onto goals and tasks and
things that i want to deliver
like i sometimes get the blinkers on in
such an intense way that
i can lose perspective on things around
me so i'm really
a lot more aware and conscious of that
now and i make sure i've got things like
that
his follow-up book was great i really
enjoyed that i actually read that and
bought it for a mutual friend of ours to
matt target over
for his birthday last year in december
so yeah so i i enjoy his reading i i
read a lot of journals i even read a lot
of harvard business review
articles um there's one i like in
particular and it's really funny this
will sound a little bit
counter-intuitive around
mental health but it's about mental
toughness
and there's you know they've got their
sort of mini books that you can you can
read all the journals that they've had
around that particular subject matter
and i love that because it resonates
with me
you know 100 so i find i actually need
to not just read things that give me
renewed perspective but actually things
that make me feel more like me
and that's one of the things that the
psychologist that i've
um dealt with because you know we always
talk about purpose and meaning and all
this sort of stuff
and and he had this really interesting
thing that he said to me because you
know
people have this high expectation of you
once you've achieved certain things in
life and and
you have a greater expectation of
yourself more than anybody else and he
just said to me goes
just do more things that make you feel
like you
and that has always stuck with me
because it's like okay what do i value
what what i truly value and it's funny i
that upon the basis of that saying or
that statement
i i really got back to my own core
values and then i did things that
sort of checked into those values um
and it's funny because i always had
people tell me
oh grant just just slow down just you
know
enjoy it just relax don't you know don't
try and do everything to to the top
level every single time
i hate when people say that [ __ ] god it
pisses me off so much
i i tried that and you know what i
realized that's not me
like doing things mediocre is not me i
can't
stand that and it was funny all the
things that disconnected with my value
set
destabilized me and so i
focus on reading things reading journals
doing things that connect more with me
and those things like mental tough
toughness reading about navy seals
reading about
different training strategies that sort
of stuff i i really love and
i find that an escape for my personality
so that that's quite interesting and
then i
i love commerce and love business so i i
read a lot of different business books
and
and articles so they're kind of the
things that that i just enjoy
so yeah it's always just reconnecting
with purpose for me that actually um
slows my mind down gives me perspective
and then yeah the books that i just
referred to
um certainly have um helped me round out
that view
even more so do you have any favorite
since you mentioned it i know this this
might seem off topic but it's not
since this is about your lives and not
just once
one facet any particular favorite
business books and i'll just mention for
folks also
uh harvard business review has a book
which is hbr's
10 must reads on mental toughness and
features
martin seligman tony schwartz warren
bennis and others
and that's a that's 24 25 you can find
that online and i'll link to that in the
show notes
are there any business books that's that
are real standouts for you
uh there's one i'm reading at the moment
that i'm really enjoying um which is
phil knight
shoedoll uh i've gotta read this book
it's
it's i've got to read it it's been
recommended to me 100 times yeah
so so i'm in the middle of that i'm
going to say that's that's definitely
one that springs to mind that's um
definitely definitely top of the list
other ones that stand out i mean
probably that one for now
the other ones that i enjoy reading i
enjoy just general sort of leadership
um so i read a lot of stuff that relates
to that in business
and knowing and understanding what the
fundamentals are i've probably got
if i walked into my bedroom seven or
eight books that i want to read
that i haven't at the moment i always
enjoy reading things
around warren buffett i've read a lot of
books that relate to him just on his
mindset and
his approach towards things because the
one thing that i've really found in high
performance
you don't actually have to read always
on your specific subject matter because
and when it comes to business i always
find i read articles mostly like
strategy articles or
you know growth initiatives or you know
what was the change in
boeing when you know airbus when airbus
said okay we got to do the a380 but
you know what if if we get this wrong
it's actually going to send us bankrupt
you know what was the inflection point
where business became great
and i enjoy jim collins like his book's
good to great are really interesting
just to learn about
you know i find any sort of success
story is the same it is just a daily
grind of mundane things that you just
have to keep getting right and improve
by 0.1 of a percent and then do it again
the next day then do it again the next
day then eventually
you know momentum and the flywheel as
it's referred to in that books
kind of click into place and and then
all of a sudden
many years later you've got this
outstanding result that people think is
an
overnight success that took you 15 years
to get there so
that's the way i find most things work
and so i love reading around the
principles of you know high performance
and success in any single field whether
it's a navy seal whether it's business
whether it's sport whether it's
you know in music you know the school of
julia like whatever it might be
those principles are the same and i'm
always trying to to identify those
because
i got to be honest i love it like i'm
passionate about it i'm passionate about
learning about it talking about it
reading about it so yeah they're
probably always
the things that i try and um tap into
and again it comes back to that that
saying that i said before just do things
that make you feel more like you that's
that's not everyone's cup of tea
winning olympic gold medals is not
everybody's cup of tea because
sacrifice you have to make for that for
most people is probably not often worth
it but for the two guys you've got on
this call
we'll do anything to to get those things
and sort of have the same approach to
everything else that i try and achieve
or want to achieve
i love that expression doing more things
that make you feel like you i've never
heard
anything or never heard the message
worded quite that way but it's very
succinct and very
deep if you if you spend some time on it
so thank you for sharing
that michael are there any other books
or resources that that you would
like to mention just to give you another
dip at the well
i was sitting here looking at my like
the little bookshelf that we have behind
uh
we've scattered in here but i was
sitting here looking at these books and
i
there's there's two of them that popped
into my head that one i've gone back to
so for trying to slow things down i i
tried to mix in more of a daily reading
so uh mark nepo has a good one the book
of awakening
and then uh the daily stoic i mean i
feel like some of those things
you know yeah you know you can really
just like almost just take a step back
right take a deep breath
let it you know read a quote read you
know a single page whatever it is
let it marinate and and you know just
for me it's just something that's so
easy to do but something it's so awesome
to do to start your day you know i just
feel like it just gives you some kind of
purpose of what you're doing and and
you know when when life is too fast
again it gives you that second to
take that step back yeah daily stoic and
ego is the enemy you got a whole lot of
ryan holiday on your bookshelf
it's funny because so i i i just got the
daily start from my coach
uh or my my old code sorry bob bowman
and
um i've gotten a few of the other books
as i was saying earlier from
you know seth hackie right yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah he he's he's like he's
one of like my favorite human beings on
this planet to have a
communication or a conversation with
excuse me um but some of the books that
he's given me
really have like like he he i feel like
he has a really good understanding
about me as a person and how i work and
and he's a very very smart human being
so i feel like some of the things that
he's given me to read
are again back to my point just simple
ways for me
to understand something that i might be
too hard on myself with or
you know i might be too hyper focused on
one thing right so you know almost
giving me that bigger picture
um you know trying to be that lake
instead of being that glass of water so
yeah i think like a lot of a lot of the
books that i have
that i'll rifle through time and time
again
uh i think have been super helpful just
to yeah i mean i i think
more than anything just give me a chance
like i i feel you know for me like a lot
of my life was
focused on swimming and and um that
really was it like
you know it's hacky hack you know as
being an olympian your whole life is
focused on one thing
nothing else matters in life but that
i'm honestly
really learning how to live on dry land
so to say
um you know i kind of made the joke
throughout the last uh
last few years i feel like i've taken
more strokes in the swimming pool than
i've taken steps on land
um so it's uh it's it's it makes it
challenging when you have a freight
train
trying to come down the middle of the
tree the street with no tracks on it
so it's been difficult at times slowing
me down but but i feel
like some of those simple you know kind
of different approaches to looking at
things
um for me just have benefited so much
just
because i i can't expect to fill up
everybody's
cups if my cup isn't filled up right
like i have
you know i have three boys and an
amazing wife and and
a household here that i'm i'm in charge
of my roles right so
if if i'm not taking care of myself and
you know filling my glass up by taking
the time that i need for me
i have no shot in being able to be a
good husband
a good friend a good dad so
you know i i just want i want to have a
chance and and i feel like that's what i
did in my career my preparation
it was the process like it was the whole
process of it all that that i learned
but
you know the preparation was was you
know so key
so it's it's yeah just trying to slow
things down i don't know
if any of that makes sense but yeah it's
something that it does
um yeah it's been it's been enjoyable
but but as you can imagine
something that's been extremely
challenging at times you know as you
hear grant and i talk about
we want to go fast and we like we want
to get to uh point a to point b as fast
as we can the fastest way but also the
most effective way
so how can we do it you know what i mean
so it's like
you know people are like mine's going
yeah
sometimes you want to be the lake and
other times you want to take a jet ski
at 100 miles an hour across the lake
and some days it's hard to decide which
one you want to do
right right
oh man well this this has been such
a fun conversation for me and i i just
have
uh one more question and it's it's
sometimes a difficult question so if it
doesn't work it doesn't work but we'll
i'll give it a shot and that is
actually before i get there i have to
say i've also found stoicism very very
helpful and
it's it's such a small world because i
actually
published the audiobook versions of both
egos the enemy and the daily stoic
believe it or not
your voice a lot i've heard it a lot i
think you've done pc you've done some
stuff with uh trevor mohammad as well
i believe uh i i i may have yeah
it's it's really wrong it might be wrong
it's just
such a such a small world so let me ask
a question that sometimes
doesn't work because it is sometimes a
hard question i'll ask it of both of you
and the question is this
if you could put anything on a billboard
this is metaphorically speaking
it could be an image a quote a question
a word
anything non-commercial on a billboard
to get something in front of
billions of people what would it be
and uh if either of you want to take a
stab at it
feel free to jump if you want hacky yeah
you want to go go
through my head but um you go first bud
uh i mean i i would just say it's okay
to not be okay you know i think that's
something that that
for me um you know even in my darkest
scariest moments like
that's that's the one thing that nicole
always says to me um you know and she'll
throw around around me or ask if she can
give me a hug sometimes
you know if i am just like if i really
want to be alone like
that's the one thing like she'll she'll
ask me because sometimes i just need
that moment by myself she'll ask to give
me a hug
my wife will ask me to give me a hug so
you know like it's it's
she like we've just been able to i mean
again i can't say it enough it grows so
much so
you know i i would say again to
everybody out there like it's okay to
not be okay and
and you're not alone like those those
two things i think can just go together
just i mean with everything we've talked
about on this call uh it's just
i mean it's it's in in a difficult time
it's
it's something to just simplify it take
a step back
deep breath and relax those are great
those are great grant any thoughts yeah
the first thing that popped into my head
and i often think that's always the
right
and best answer was if you want to put
something in a billboard um i just
be you be you be here
two words very simple because the more
you do the things that
uh you know make you feel like yourself
it brings out your personality brings
out who you
are makes you feel good about yourself
and you don't have to be something
that's false or superficial or
create an image for anybody else or
anything else and i think once you get
back to
that simplification and to michael's
point i think um
you know often you feel best about
yourself often you find the things that
you enjoy doing more often
often enough you're living a life that
just makes you feel good about yourself
and um
and and you know connect better with the
people around you so i think
um just be you and feel comfort
comfortable in that
excellent exactly good man like i
honestly that's like i i
i can just hearing you say that through
through the last
you know hour that we've that you've
mentioned it to me like it's
brought up so many things that that
would help me just like simplify life
and it just totally makes sense
you know like there are times like i i i
can say like i i mean i i play golf with
or i've had the chance to play golf with
a lot of professional golfers and and
you know i recently got to play with you
know i got to know john rahm a little
bit so the first time playing with him
i'm like [ __ ] like
i want to try to play as good as i can
like i want to be on my you know a game
yada yada yada and i'm like well that's
not me because i don't have the time and
the preparation
to perform how i expect to perform so i
i can't expect to be somebody else
i have to be me that's something that
that you know i
struggled a lot with and at times still
do you know without like where where i
feel like sometimes i am just a swimmer
and because i feel like that's
what the story has been right you know
every single headline is about swimming
swimming swimming and
and you know finally now like that like
that's why i've really i'm so happy with
everything we're doing with mental
health but
you know like that's that's one thing
that i really just saw myself as
and and not a human being so you know i
i want to say thank you because
like that that quote right there just be
you
um you know i think can simplify a
thousand things for me
i don't know how i've never heard you
even say that but thanks i appreciate
you bringing that up today
like you before and it just popped into
my head i just went with it
well this is this has been uh really fun
to have both of you on and for everybody
listening we'll we'll link to everything
in the show notes as usual at tim dot
blog forward slash podcast so you won't
miss anything
the documentary that was mentioned is
the weight of gold
that is an hbo documentary grant
people can find you on instagram at
grant underscore
underscore hackett h-a-c-k-e-t-t
two underscores and then michael people
can find you
on twitter at michael phelps facebook
michael phelps
instagram at m underscore phelps zero
zero is there anything else that you
gentlemen would would like to mention
anything else that you'd like to add
as a closing comment or or anything at
all
um i gotta say i i just i'm so proud of
uh
michael as a friend you know he knows i
love him like a brother and you know
but um people have seen him as a product
right because a guy's so successful and
so amazing and achieve things that no
one
else ever has in the history of sport
and
um but to hear how open and
honest and transparent and forthright he
is around mental health
because i know he wants to help other
people to to me is just an outstanding
characteristic
and um you could never underestimate the
strength
but michael always has that strength um
to to do that sort of stuff so
yeah man that was it was awesome to hear
you today it was it was emotional for me
sitting on the other side because i've
been there i've been right there with
you sitting in the closet
talking
that's just been awesome and i've really
enjoyed that today and um
look i'm sure that that will help a lot
of people and and i know that's exactly
what you like to do
exactly honestly likewise bro i mean
we've both been through
uh our fair share of ups and downs
publicly and privately and and um
you know as you know my my circle is
super tight and
and i love you like a brother and
honestly this
it's it's awesome to see uh the journey
that you've been on and and
honestly just welcoming a new baby geez
it's it's so cool so special
awesome to watch i miss you like hell as
as as selfish as it is i wish you lived
next door
we need our compound i know we'll
honestly this is it's been great you
know for for me you know
even though with with the relationship
and and as close as i am with hackie
i've been able to learn even more about
him today and and
uh you know i'm excited that we
somebody finally put this together the
two of us to be able to just
chat for for two hours um honestly it
was a treat
um and and you know we've listened to uh
a lot of you over the years i look
forward to listening to a lot more
um if it's okay i'd love to grab your
email
from your team and and stay in touch and
honestly if you have any books or
anything
i i truly add something that that um
as i said i think i think i've read more
books in the last five years
or listened to more books in the last
five years than i have in the previous
30 um
you know so i think it's it's funny how
life works and
and how open i am or how much more open
i am now and
and you know that wall is down a little
bit more um
so yeah anything that you know i'm
always uh eager to learn and
and um this it's it's just been a fun
process i i i can't thank you enough for
for having us on today this is this is a
true treat yeah total blast for me
a an experiment certainly especially
scattered across the world as we are
and it worked out i'm so happy that we
were able to come together
and thanks for the kind words also uh i
you know the book the book that i would
recommend more than any other is not one
of mine it's actually a book called
awareness by
anthony demello it's a short book
d-e-m-e-l-l-o anthony demelo
and i will definitely i'll share my
email and sell
with both of you guys and you can feel
free to reach out anytime certainly
and hopefully we'll we'll meet in person
sometime
and it has been such a treat uh so so
thank you both very much
and uh i wish you both a
wonderful weekend you too thank you so
much for having us kim
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
butcherbox butcherbox makes it easy for
you to get high quality humanely raised
meat
you can trust they deliver delicious 100
grass-fed grass-finished beef free-range
organic chicken
heritage breed pork and wild caught
seafood directly to your door
for me in the past few weeks i've cooked
a ton of their salmon
as well as two delicious barbecue rib
racks in the oven
super simple they were the most
delicious pork ribs i've ever prepared
my freezer is full of butcher box when
you become a member
you're joining a community focused on
doing what's better for all that means
caring about the lives of animals
the livelihoods of farmers treating our
planet with respect and enjoying
better meals together witcherbox
partners with folks small farmers
included who believe in going above and
beyond
when it comes to caring for animals the
environment and sustainability
and none of their meat is ever given
antibiotics or added hormones
so how does it work it's pretty simple
you choose your box and your
delivery frequency they offer five boxes
four
curated box options as well as the
popular custom box so you get exactly
what you
and or your family love box options and
delivery frequencies can be customized
to fit your needs you can cancel
at any time with no penalty butcherbox
ships your order frozen for freshness
and packed in an eco-friendly 100
recyclable box it's easy it's fast
it's convenient i really really enjoy it
and best of all looking at the average
cost it works out to be less than six
dollars per meal get ready for game day
or cozy night in with butcher box
right now new members will get one rack
of st louis style ribs
one pack of bacon and a pack of pulled
pork for free
in their first box by going to
butcherbox.com
tim one more time that's butcherbox.com
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than thirty percent of americans
struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes
of poor sleep and heat has always been
my nemesis i've suffered for decades
tossing and turning throwing blankets
off putting them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now i am
falling asleep
in record time faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device
called the pod pro cover by eight sleep
it's the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best
tools for sleep enhancing sleep
and asleep was by far and away the
crowd favorite i mean people were just
raving fans of this
so i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress and
start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat then we can
have our own bespoke temperatures
on either side which is exactly what
we're doing now for me
and for many people the result eight
sleep users fall asleep up to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40
and get more restful sleep overall i can
personally attest to this because i
track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get 250
off of the pod pro cover that's a lot
simply go to eight
sleep dot com slash tim or use code tim
that's eight all spelled out e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use
coupon code tim t-i-m eight sleep dot
com
slash tim for 200 off your pot